I uh write down the date and time every
time I go poop I have done so for the
last I think four years
there was a brief period of time in my
early 20s where I had five boyfriends at
the same time they all believed that
they were my boyfriends
and I guess they all were depending on
the day
My secret is is that I sold a bunch of
feet photos during the pandemic to make
a lot of money they were very willing to
pay me and I was very willing to sell my
photos
so when I was a kid uh me and my
brothers we used to uh eat our
grandfather's cigar ashes we used to eat
a bunch of other weird stuff like
topping powder tree bark but yeah not a
cigar ashes they had such a
distinguished flavor to them so that's
probably why I smoke now
I'm in love with my best friend
I've had a crush on one of my closest
friends for like two years now I still
have feelings for my high school ex I'm
still
in love with my ex I hired a voodoo
witch on Etsy to cast a love spell on my
ex
and I casted it about two weeks ago so
we're still waiting to see if it works
um my ex-boyfriend lit my house on fire
okay so this one time I was out in West
Hollywood with a friend she got really
drunk so I brought her home and she
started throwing up right in my living
room and I held her hair back but the
smile was so bad that I ended up
throwing up on her head
and I never had the guts to tell her
about it
so once in college I was sitting near my
English professor and he had a long
sticker on his butt cheek that had the
pant size and I kept trying to single
signal to him that he had it on and I
kept pointing to his butt cheek and he
didn't really get it and then I kind of
just started pointing to mine and then
he started getting flustered and
admittedly kind of uncomfortable and he
really wouldn't get it and so then I
just kind of like got closer to him and
like kind of like turned my body and
kind of showed him like kind of my butt
cheek area and pointed to mine and then
says and then he finally got it but it
kind of took a second and I'm pretty
sure he thought that I was trying to hit
on him in a really horrible way in front
of everybody so English class
okay I think that I've honestly peed my
pants more than like the average adult
person has peed their pants in their
life like probably five times since I've
turned 18. it's just who I am I don't
know what to tell you I'm sorry
[Music]
to grow a ton of marijuana before it
became legal and I was doing this all
while I was a middle school teacher and
I did that for about
um
seven years and made a ton of cash
okay
I never thought that place on Earth was
Disneyland I always thought it was
McDonald's and Disneyland was second so
when I was little my dream job was to
work at McDonald's specifically to make
the french fries and work in the window
it's like the happiest place on earth
like it had the playground and then they
had the fries and the little Happy Meal
toys and then it was just it had
everything
[Music]
foreign
when I was a kid I still do this
whenever I'm at museums or like exhibits
and stuff I always try and touch every
single thing
especially when it says no touch
[Music]
once I
stole a really cool looking napkin ring
from an open house when I was like eight
years old and I felt so bad I wrote a
letter to the homeowners association
telling them I was sorry
[Music]
I think my girlfriend is in love with
her ex and I ignore it
[Music]
my best friend told me that he was in
love with me and I felt the same way but
I never told him that I loved him too
[Music]
when I was 15 I was in a school shooting
at my high school and I feel like I
never fully got over my PTSD and every
day I live I always have a fear that
somewhere something is going to happen
again
[Music]
um I say I don't like children and I
don't want them ever but I think I'm
just secretly afraid I'll mess them up
like my parents messed me up
[Music]
one secret that I don't really tell
people except for my closest friends is
that I have really bad social anxiety
I've gotten really good at pretending
like I'm really social but I'm actually
not and I'm always viewing myself
through other people's eyes and it's
really stressful so on this trip with my
friends I'm trying to just be myself and
like not think about anything too much
[Music]
so I am a trans woman and I have not
come out to a whole lot of people yet
um
so yeah and my name is Isabella
[Music]
so all my life I've really sacrificed
everything for everyone else doing all I
could to make everyone happy and feel
loved
and
um
that was okay up until like the other
day my mom told me that she didn't want
me in her life and that I was a mess and
basically saying I wasn't lovable and I
kind of just realized that making those
sacrifices aren't always deserved and I
do love her but I'm going to live my
life for me even if it scares me even if
it doesn't get approval from anyone else
because
this is my life
um
that's a very
difficult realization
[Music]
this is a little bit of a secret that
I've had since I was a lot younger I've
always kind of struggled internally with
like masculine and feminine energy I've
always been told that I need to be you
know like way more masculine and not so
like sensitive and not so
feminine according to like a lot of my
you know cultural upbringing and stuff
so it was something that I used to
struggle with a lot and as a kid I did a
lot of martial arts I used to literally
go into my uh go to my mom's like closet
and grab grab all like a bunch of her
clothes and uh put on all of her clothes
and then hit the crap out of stuff to
try to like kill like the feminine
energy inside of me yeah it was always
really really tough but as I got older I
kind of accepted that a whole lot more
and I actually ended up opening up a
Muay Thai gym to where I can have like a
really safe space to be both to let out
my masculine energy when needed and
retain my feminine being as I am without
feeling judged or without feeling bad
about myself
[Music]
um
my dad my parents disowned me when I was
18 for not being Christian I'm 25 now
and I've done a lot of healing and
um made a lot of progress in forgiveness
but I kind of wear this face that I
don't give a [__] that they disowned me
that I don't care that
you know I that I hate them but
deep down I want more than anything to
my dad just to tell me that he loves me
[Music]
so when I was 16 years old I was with my
boyfriend I realized that I accidentally
got pregnant
I thought my burdens were gonna take it
well because they're very liberal
and it was kind of the contrary they
were extremely disappointed with me and
they immediately shut me down I didn't
feel supported whatsoever so of course I
decided to abort and as soon as I
decided that they told me that under
absolutely no circumstance I was to ever
told tell anyone about my abortion and
about the whole experience not my best
friends not my friends not even my
boyfriend not my brother not my family
members no one so I felt absolutely
alone at 16 years old and
I felt like I've been carrying this
absolutely massive secret with me
because I was even told to lie during in
medical records when I went to the
gynecologist and still many people in my
life don't know that I went through this
at 16 years old even my brother my uncle
my aunts and many of my friends
hey everyone I just want to let you know
that I recently published a book it's
called a book of secrets and basically
it's just a collection of Secrets from
strangers all around the world so if
you're interested and you want a copy
I'll have it linked in my description
thank you for watching this episode I
love you all and I'll see you next time